TRACE: When a man and a woman love each other
very much…
CRYSTAL: Her body takes a small piece of his
DNA and something completely destroys any
evidence of its presence!
CRYSTAL: Hey DNews!
Crystal and Trace here, thanks for stopping
by!
So, you probably know the basics: sperm meets
egg, fertilization occurs, and the father’s
DNA in the lucky sperm is combined with the
mother’s in her egg to complete the set
of 46 chromosomes needed to make a human.
TRACE: But that's just chromosomal DNA, humans
and most animals have a little more DNA than
just what's contained in our chromosomes...
CRYSTAL: It's true that chromosomal DNA is
the big famous one.
It's folded into chromosomes, stored in the
cell nucleus, and contains almost all the
directions for how to make a human.
Almost!
TRACE: We also have mitochondrial DNA, which
contain a few instructions on how to make
very specialized, proteins.
CRYSTAL: Mitochondria are little sub-compartments
inside the cell, but outside the nucleus.
They're the powerhouse of the cell, and are
responsible for producing energy that keeps
cells alive.
But they also contain this DNA.
Mitochondrial DNA is circular, and shorter
than chromosomal DNA.
The mitochondria are special not just because
they have their own tiny genome, but because
they can only be inherited from your mother.
TRACE: Which is weird, because dude's cells
definitely have mitochondria.
Without the energy male mitochondria provide
sperm, they couldn't swim all that way.
But, after they contact the egg: POOF, the
mtDNA it's nowhere to be found!
It's a huge biological mystery.
The paternal mitochondrial DNA never enters
the egg, but its chromosomal DNA does.
Where's all the mtDNA from your pops?
CRYSTAL: Well, the Case of the Disappearing
DNA has lots of twists and turns.
Scientists hypothesized that lysosomes in
the egg were attacking paternal DNA, leading
to degradation.
Lysosomes are the cell’s waste disposal
system, sub compartments of the cell that
are spherical packages of killer enzymes to
cut up and destroy proteins and DNA.
TRACE: They sound dangerous, and they're not
the whole story.
Earlier studies also showed that mitochondria
in sperm carry specific signals that might
mark them for death even before they started
swimming for their lives.
CRYSTAL: But, this month, researchers in China
published a report in the journal Science
that suggests the paternal mitochondria have
a self-destruct mechanism that activates during
fertilization.
TRACE: Yep, they might do it to themselves.
That means all of the mitochondria in all
humans today is from the mother, and thus
can be traced back to one common female ancestor,
scientists call this person “mitochondrial
Eve”.
CRYSTAL: When researchers examined paternal
mitochondria using an electron microscope
they found that instead of the father’s
mitochondria being destroyed by mechanisms
within the egg, the mitochondria began to
decompose on their own!
They found that an enzyme, CPS-6, was responsible
for this degradation.
TRACE: Essentially, mitochondria from the
Dad are depolarized and damaged internally
soon after fertilization, this leads to the
release of that CPS-6.
CRYSTAL: Which then starts chewing up the
mitochondrial DNA and then lysosomes from
the egg move in for the kill.
TRACE: As you can imagine this was a shock.
CRYSTAL: Yeah!
Basically, every sperm's mitochondria is on
a suicide mission!
TRACE: *plays taps*
CRYSTAL: Why would evolution only select for
maternal mtDNA?
How is that an advantage?
TRACE: DISEASE!
See, mitochondrial DNA could be used to help
us overcome genetic diseases…
To learn about how soon one baby could have
three genetic parents, check out this video
by Laci.
Are you sad about your mitochondria, now that
you know them so well?
Have a science question you want us to tackle?